هلا اطلق النار على قدمين
يتاهب الرجل لمرحله جديده اخرها كان
علامات توثيق بالوان مختلفه ذهبي رمادي
وازرق كلن حسب الجهه وكله هذا يتم برفقه
مجموعه محدوده من الموظفين بعد زلزال
للاقالات والاستقالات فما الذي يريد ماسك
ايصاله بالنسبه لمشتركين تويتر الامر
واكثر سوده
اذا بدا وكان منصات على نفسها مبكرا وهذا
ما جاء في الوسم الذي انتشر مؤخرا برنس
تويتر
عاما من التغريد لكن هل الامر بهذا السوق
يبدو ذلك من يرى ان الى الماسك ان يتخبط
ولا يعرف ماذا يفعل غير ان ماسك رد ساخرا
بهذه الصوره
فهل ينهض ماسك فعلا تويتر ثم من يتوقع غير
ذلك فاستمرار العمل بشكل الطبيعي في
الشركه بات مستحيلا لا معايير في تسريح
الموظفين والاضطراب والارتباكوبته
المسيطرين
التوقعات متشائمه الاضطرابات تعصف
بالعصفور وثمت من يتوقع تكرار الاغلاق في
المكاتب العالميه لماذا مجزره الاقالات
والاستقالات هي السبب وحتى ترامب لم يرى
اي سببا يدفعه للعوده الى تويتر رغم
التصويت الذي صبا في صالح عوده
تفعيل حساب الرئيس الامريكي السابق لكن
حديثه لم يخلو من اشاراته اشاراتنا
الاضطرابات الداخليه في تويتر مستقبل
ضبابيا اذا تمت من يرى ان سياسات سياسات
راسماليات تطل براسها ومخاوف على حريته
الراي والتعليم
احذروا تويتر قد يتوقف او ينهار المصير
الغامض لتويتر بعد موجه الايقالات
والاستقالات خاصه من المهندسين الذين
يشرفون على صيانته دفع الى هذا التحذير
لاسيما خلال كاس العالم بسبب العدد
الهائلي من الزوار الملك الجديد الى الماس
تحدي المحذرين ودعى الى متابعه تويتر
والسبب تغطيه افضل للمونديال وذلك رغم
الاعطال الكثيره حول العالم قد تكون هذه
الاعطال بسبب مليون و600 الف المستخدم
نشره يوميا خلال الايام الماضيه رقم اعلنه
مصر ووصفه بالاعلى على الاطلاق لكن ماذا
عن المستقبل ماسك بدا مرحله جديده من
التوظيف المهندسون وموظفون المبيعات لهم
الاولويه بينما وفي خطبه فسرها البعض
بانها تراجع وبعد ما صرحهم دعا ماسك
مهندسين مستقلين الى العوده هل بسبب
مطالبات التحقيق معه ربما